preso por fraude.
Fui deshonesto y pagué el precio.
Antes de eso, trabajé como abogado durante 30 años.
Tuve una crianza feliz y estable,
una buena educación,
un matrimonio feliz, el cual, me complace decir, continúa.
Tengo dos hijos adultos.
Cuando estaban creciendo, hice lo mejor por estar cerca de ellos
lo más que podía.
Le puse cuidadoso interés a lo que hacían.
Les leía cada noche,
e irónicamente, nuestra historia favorita era "El ladrón Bill."
(Risas)
Pero cuando fui a prisión, pronto se hizo obvio
que mi pasado era muy diferente al de la mayoría de prisioneros.
Pocos de los hombres que conocí habían tenido una educación decente.
En verdad, muchos asociaban la educación con humillación y fracaso.
Puedo decirles de primera mano que la prisión deshumaniza.
Los prisioneros se endurecen, se cierran, asedian...
solo para sobrevivir.
Y esto puede ser devastador para las familias.
De hecho, mantener contacto con tu familia desde la prisión
puede ser realmente difícil.
Y si un niño puede ver a su padre en prisión,
deben soportar los mismos cateos que los adultos.
Pasan por los mismos detectores de metales,
los huelen los perros detectores,
y todo porque algunos niños han sido inocentes portadores
de drogas o teléfonos celulares.
Y cuando pasan para ver a su padre,
pueden estar cansados por el largo viaje,
tímidos, callados, y hasta molestos.
Y no es fácil para los padres, quienes podrían no llevarse bien.
Por muchas razones, no solo estas,
más de la mitad de los prisioneros pierden contacto con sus hijos y familias.
¿Cómo podemos ayudar a los prisioneros a estar en contacto con sus familias?
Cuando estaba preso en la Prisión Channings Wood
empecé a trabajar para una organización benéfica llamada Storybooks Dads.
Storybooks Dads empezó en el 2003,
cuando Sharon Berry, una trabajadora civil de una prisión, se dio cuenta de cuánto
muchos prisioneros querían permanecer en contacto con sus hijos.
Y así, armada con algunos libros de cuentos,
empezó a ayudar a los prisioneros a leer y grabar cuentos
para enviar a casa a sus hijos.
No era una idea nueva. Pocas ideas así son nuevas.
Son grandes ideas.
Pero fue éxito inmediato.
Se preguntarán: ¿cómo funcionan los cuentos grabados en prisión?
¿Es difícil para los reclusos?
¿Puede ser un desafío?
Bueno, el proceso de escoger, leer y grabar una historia
puede ser un desafío para los reclusos.
La prisión es dura,
y los presos no pueden mostrar señales de debilidad o vulnerabilidad.
Pero este proceso de grabación
puede ser incómodo, molesto, algunas veces abrumador.
Y los internos a menudo lloran.
Lloran porque lamentan perderse las vidas de sus hijos.
Lloran porque tienen vergüenza por haber defraudado a sus familias.
Lloran porque no saben cómo leerles a sus hijos.
Pero cuando vienen a nosotros les ofrecemos un lugar privado, individual,
y los reclusos no necesitan ser rudos,
y pueden usar su vulnerabilidad como una fortaleza
al contactarse con sus hijos.
Recuerdo un prisionero que vino a grabar.
Era un hombre alto, fuerte, con reputación de ser rudo.
Vino tan implacable como siempre.
Pero cuando la puerta de la sala de grabación se cerró,
esa fachada empezó a desmoronarse.
De su bolsillo, sacó un pedazo de papel estrujado
y empezó a leer en voz baja
lo que había escrito como mensaje para sus dos pequeños.
Sus manos temblaban.
Y luego, con una voz sorprendentemente suave,
empezó a cantar su canción de cuna favorita.
Vean, no había mucho que podía hacer desde la prisión
para mostrar a sus hijos que los extrañaba y los amaba.
Pero podía hacer esto.
Una vez que se hace la grabación,
se envía a la unidad de producción de Storybook Dads
en la Prisión Channings Wood en Devon.
Y ahí es donde yo trabajaba.
Me habían entrenado, junto con otros reclusos,
para editar y producir grabaciones enviadas
desde prisiones de todo el Reino Unido.
Usando software de audio y vídeo,
se eliminan los errores de las grabaciones
y se añaden música y efectos de sonido.
Y la experiencia y las habilidades que aprenden los editores de la prisión
les ayudan para empleos futuros.
Una vez terminada la grabación,
se transfiere a un CD o DVD y se envía a las familias
para que los hijos puedan verlas cuando lo necesiten.
Y ellos escuchan estas grabaciones y las ven mucho...
a la hora de dormir, en el auto...
Algunos incluso las llevan a la escuela para mostrarlas a sus amigos.
Estas grabaciones
muestran a los niños que son amados y extrañados.
Y le muestran al recluso
que puede hacer algo por su hijo, como padre.
¿Recuerdan a Sophie?
Bueno, un día, justo antes de Navidad, llegó un paquete,
y esto venía dentro.
Escuchemos un poco juntos.
(Vídeo) Santa: ¡Vamos Cometa! ¡Cupido, Donner y Blitzen!
Charlie: Ese es su reno, ¿cierto?
Santa: Es su reno, sí.
Arriba, más y más alto volaron,
sobre tierra y océanos fueron rápido.
Pasaron a través de las mágicas auroras boreales...
Me encantaría ver las auroras boreales, ¿a ti no?
Charlie: Quizás se vean un poco como la barriga del muñeco de nieve.
Santa: Quizás, sí.
Es un muñeco de nieve genial, ¿cierto?
Charlie: Muy genial en verdad. Me encanta.
Santa: Visitaron a todos los niños del mundo
y dejaron regalos para cada uno.
En un abrir y cerrar de ojos, regresaron a Frogsbottom Field.
(Charlie se ríe).
Santa: ¿Crees que es muy gracioso?
Charlie: ¡Quiero vivir en Frogsbottom Field!
Santa: ¿Dónde vives, en el Árbol Frogsbottom?
Charlie: No, vivo en este árbol.
Hice que se vea navideño.
Santa: Está bueno.
Buen trabajo, un buen trabajo.
Charlie: ¡Muchas gracias!
(Risas)
Alan Crickmore: Sophie y su mamá lo escucharon tres veces,
y no se han reído tanto en mucho tiempo.
Pueden ver que él está bien, pueden ver que las ama,
y la próxima vez que llame, Sophie tiene mucho de qué hablar:
"¿Qué come Charlie el Chimpancé?
¿Papá creará otra historia pronto?".
Desde que empezó en el 2003, Storybook Dads ha seguido creciendo y creciendo.
Ahora opera como Storybook Dads y Storybook Mums
en más de 100 prisiones en el Reino Unido.
El 99 % de los prisioneros que participan
dicen que ha mejorado su relación con sus hijos.
Y desde el 2003,
más de 60 000 DVD y CD se han enviado
a los hijos de los presos.
Para la familia de Sophie y para miles de familias como ellos,
Storybook Dads fue un salvavidas.
Algunos reclusos dicen que es la primera vez
que empezaron a construir una relación con sus hijos.
Y algunos lectores malos han sido tan inspirados
por lo que han podido lograr
que han tomado clases para mejorar sus habilidades de lectura.
Regresemos a la historia de "El patito feo."
Pero esta vez, me gustaría reproducirles una grabación hecha por un recluso,
porque resume el poder de lo que hacemos.
El prisionero era un nómada irlandés que no sabía leer.
Y quería enviar una historia a casa a su hija por su cumpleaños.
Con la ayuda de un tutor y una ingeniosa edición,
algo mágico sucedió.
Esto es un extracto de la grabación sin editar,
donde el reo lee la historia repitiéndola, una frase a la vez.
(Audio) Tutor: No tenía dónde esconderse.
Owen: No tenía dónde esconderse.
Tutor: Y un día, huyó.
Owen: Y un día, huyó
Tutor: Corrió hasta llegar al gran pantano.
Owen: Corrió hasta llegar al gran pantano.
Tutor: Donde vivían los patos salvajes.
Owen: Donde vivían los patos salvajes.
AC: Y esta grabación... un extracto de ella
con la voz del tutor removida y los efectos de sonido y la música añadidos.
(Audio) Owen: Él no tenía dónde esconderse.
Luego un día, huyó.
Corrió hasta llegar al gran pantano donde vivían los patos salvajes,
y se recostó en los juncales durante dos semanas.
(Música) (Patos graznan)
Algunos patos y gansos salvajes vinieron a verlo.
"Eres muy feo", le dijeron y se rieron de él.
(Patos graznan)
El patito feo escapó del gran pantano.
AC: Y así es como terminó el cuento:
(Audio) Owen: Ya no era un patito feo.
Durante el invierno, se había convertido en un hermoso cisne blanco.
Los otros cisnes lo miraron y pensaron cuán hermoso era.
"Ven con nosotros", le dijeron.
Y lo hizo.
(Sonidos de aves)
Bueno, Tiara, espero que hayas disfrutado del cuento
tanto como disfruté leyéndotelo.
No puedo esperar para estar contigo otra vez y abrazarte.
Con todo mi amor, tu papi, Owen.
Mucho amor, te extraño con todo mi corazón.
Adiós por ahora, mi amor. Adiós.
(Música)
(Fin de la música)
AC: Cuando escuchó la grabación en su celda
antes de enviarla a su hija,
lloró.
Y es una reacción muy común entre los prisioneros,
pues se dan cuentapor primera vez
que pudieron hacer algo por sus hijos
que nunca pensaron que podrían.
Se conectaron en la forma más importante,
a través de la narración de cuentos.
Y en cuanto a Sophie,
ella quiere "El Gruffalo" la próxima vez.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)